well all week we are taking you to
Anaheim California thanks to visit
Anaheim the sponsors of this segment we
had a chance to check out some of the
festive happenings going on in Southern
California here's a look at Knott's
Berry Farm
what began as a roadside Berry stand and
chicken dinner restaurant in the 1920s
has evolved into an iconic Southern
California theme park destination
[Music]
Knott's Berry Farm here you can find
roller coasters a wild wild west
experience and a warm welcome into the
peanuts family and every holiday season
the park transforms into Knott's Mary
farm so excited that you're here at
Knott's Berry Farm we're getting to
celebrate with us not Mary farb starting
November 18th extending all the way
through January 8th and now as you walk
in through those Gates you are
transforming your you're seeing our
backdrop of Knott's Berry Farm
celebrating Christmas in his Christmas
decor everywhere and it's absolutely
beautiful expect to see Magical Lights
dancing toys and holiday shows now what
I am super excited about this year aside
from our robust entertainment that we
have two shows I'm very specifically
excited about are it's our brand new two
offerings over at the walster knob
theater we have a brand new ice show
it's Snoopy's Mexican for Christmas and
we're celebrating our 40th year doing
ice shows here with a brand new show
from ice skating to lighting up the sky
on top of having ice skaters on the ice
we've taken it up in the sky as well and
we featured aerialist that we have for
snoopies nights before Christmas and
that's going to be over at the Walter
not theater we may be in Southern
California but will we see a little
snowfall while we're walking around yes
absolutely so using a Calico as our
backdrop we're taking this little old
west as you always get transported to
when you come to Knott's Berry Farm but
we have snow and glow during our evening
time the town comes to life we have our
beautiful lights that start to twinkle
we have traditional Christmas music that
starts to play and of course we have
snow you can't have Christmas without
snow right
just growing up in Las Vegas I would
come to Knott's Berry Farm all the time
we were talking a little bit about it
before it just it feels like home and it
just feels so special when you walk
through those Gates what do you love
most and what do you hope people take
away when they leave the park for me
personally when I get to come to the
park what I love is just the essence of
Christmas that you get when you're here
right you get to see our wonderful
Christmas trees you get to see our
performers in front of the trees and you
get that feeling of oh my goodness I'm
with my family this is a tradition that
I get to be here Knott's Berry Farm
isn't complete without the food and
holiday Classics we have so much fun
food that we have this year one of my
favorite things is we have our cookie
decorating we're actually standing uh
right where you can decorate some
cookies and we couldn't leave the park
without going on a roller coaster well
Chris and I are about to go on the Ghost
Rider are you ready to go on Southern
California's longest wooden roller
coaster I'm ready let's do it let's go
my favorite rides it's really fast and
really fun
we made it we made it it was fast our
eyes are watering but it was so much fun
you gotta check out the Ghost Rider
Knott's Berry Farm happening through
January